[Applaus]
[Musik]
er ist mag euch vielleicht überraschen
aber im moment gibt es etwas in der
weltpolitik das noch wichtiger ist und
noch höhere priorität besitzt als das
corona virus die rede ist von den
verhandlungen über das neue atom
abkommen mit den iran und warum sagen
wir dass diese wichtiger sein müssen als
eine schreckliche tödliche panahi nun
weil diese verhandlungen momentan in der
hauptstadt österreich stattfinden obwohl
ist auch in österreich gerade massive
kontakt beschränkungen gab und alle
bürger in den lockdown geschickt worden
da würde man doch annehmen dass die
verhandlungen mit dieser situation
ebenfalls abgesagt werden aber nein ganz
im gegenteil denn wir in diesem video
sehen werdet steht in dieser
angelegenheit sehr viel auf dem spiel zu
viel
deshalb ist wien trotz der
schwierigkeiten oder 1000 einen neuen
variante des corona wir uns bereit alles
zu tun damit die verhandlungen weiter
laufen können nur die parteien zu einer
einigung kommen auf der einen seite
steht der iran und auf der anderen eine
ganze gruppe von ländern von denen ihr
bestimmt schon erraten könnte welche das
sind es handelt sich um die europäische
union als internationale institutionen
die fünf ständigen mitglieder
sicherheitsrates und deutschland aber
wieso gerade deutschland das doch mit
atomwaffen gar nichts am hut hat keine
angst werden dieses rätsel noch früh
genug aufklären wenn er visuell politik
schon länger vor ort kennt er
wahrscheinlich schon die fünf mitglieder
des sicherheitsrates und nicht jetzt
bitte nachsprechen russland china
frankreich das vereinigte königreich und
die vereinigten staaten allerdings gibt
es hier ein kleines problem denn eines
dieser länder hat das liste atome kommen
mit den iran total über den haufen
geworfen ihr wisst von wem spreche ja
genau donald trump zieht die usa aus dem
atom abkommen mit dem iran zurück und
weshalb grüßt jetzt wieder das wort ja
ich meine das murmeltier aber urteile
selbst wir schreiben das jahr 2015 die
vereinigten staaten verhandeln mit dem
iran über einen atom abkommen und wir
schreiben das jahr 2021 die vereinigten
staaten verhandeln über ein automat
kommen mit dem iran
[Applaus]
und ok es gibt einige dinge die
unverändert bleiben aber es gibt viele
andere die sich geändert haben denn die
situation in der wir uns heute befinden
ist eine ganz andere als die 2014 und
ich spreche nicht von corona es geht um
die zeit oder vielmehr darum dass diese
verdammt knapp wird seht euch mal
folgendes ab in ihrem vierteljährlichen
bericht vom september meldete die
internationale atomenergiebehörde iaeo
dass der iran uran in einem deutlich
höheren maß an reichert als ist das
abkommen von 2015 erlaubt aber was
bedeutet das nun konkret im grunde
genommen dass uns nur noch einige monate
bleiben bis ja bis zum point of no
return denn wenn ein land erst mal über
atomwaffen verfügt ist ist so gut wie
unmöglich dies wieder rückgängig zu
machen diese nukleare zahnpasta lässt
sich nur sehr schwer wieder zurück in
die tube drücken tja und wie ihr wisst
geht es bei der urananreicherung vor
allem um die menge wir haben dies in
einem früheren wieso alb mit dem video
erklärt dass ich euch in der
beschreibung verlinken werde so uns
heute nun der iran hat uran auf über 60
prozent angereichert das ist schon
ziemlich viel als dieses video gedreht
wurde besaß der iran noch keine
atombombe doch diese gefahr rückt immer
näher
aber warum ist es so brandgefährlich
wenn der iran eine atombombe besitzt
welche hindernisse gibt es bei der
verhandlung des abkommens gibt es
wirklich grund zu der annahme dass ist
dieses mal zustande kommen wird und
warum ist das neue atom abkommen so
wichtig nicht nur für die iran sondern
für uns alle motto wenn wir all diese
drückenden fragen beantworten und zwar
zuerst mit einem schnellen blick in die
geschichte
[Musik]
irans atomprogramm in nur zwei minuten
in föhren visual politik videos haben
wir bereits mehrfach darüber berichtet
wie sich das iranische atomprogramm
entwickelt hat und was dagegen
unternommen wurde wenn ihr tiefer in
diese thematik eintauchen folgt
abonniert bitte unbedingt unseren kanal
und stöbert ruhig auch in den älteren
videos herum da findet sich noch so
manche interessant ist aber keine sorge
wenn euch dafür jetzt die zeit fehlt wir
geben euch hier eine schnelle
zusammenfassung
[Musik]
wir schreiben das jahr 1957 unter der
regierung des schahs beginnt der iran
mit seinem atomprogramm
wer hilft ihnen dabei genau ihr bester
freund zu diesem zeitpunkt die usa wir
schreiben das jahr 1979 die revolution
der schafe gestürzt und iran der zu
einer islamischen republik das ist der
iran bis heute kennen ein sehr
konservatives regime mit einer fixen
idee eine atombombe zu bauen und israel
auszulöschen aus diesem grunde wurde
1982 das atomprogramm wieder gestartet
2002 die er entdeckt diesen
größenwahnsinnigen nuklearen
bestrebungen und es werden
internationale sanktionen verhängt 2003
der iran ist bereit zu verhandeln und
geht sogar so weit sein atomprogramm
vorübergehend einzustellen zumindest
offiziell
dann kommt das jahr 2006 um die
urananreicherung wird wieder erhöht
hinzu kommt dass der iran ausländischen
beobachtern den zugang zu seinen
nuklearanlagen verwehrt wir schreiben
das jahr 2013 die usa und der iran neben
offizielle verhandlungen über ein
mögliches atom ab kommt auf zwei jahre
später steigt weißer rauch auf wir haben
das abkommen es liegt dem
höchstzulässigen anreicherungsgrad auf
unter 4 prozent fest und bestimmte menge
an uran die der iran lagern darf alles
sollte darauf hin dass die welt in
sicherheit ist der iran wird keine
atombombe bauen wieder zumindest
offiziell
[Musik]
aber dann kommt das jahr 2018 und eines
schönen tages sagt der protagonistin
weißen haus und trank ich dachte die usa
aus dem atom abkommen aussteigen lassen
aber warum tut er das weil israel in
verraten hat dass der iran gegen das
abkommen verstößt die usa ziehen sich
also aus dem abkommen zurück verhängen
neue sanktionen gegen den iran und
bringen damit die wirtschaft des landes
zum erliegen und was macht er ihre eine
gegenzug erreicht noch mehr uran über
das zulässige maß hinaus an diesmal
sogar ganz speziell dann im jahr 2021
setzt sich der neue präsident der usa
die beiden das ziel das angeblich von
verursachte chaos zu korrigieren und
will die verhandlungen mit dem iran
wieder aufnehmen diese entscheidung
führt uns nun nach wien aber warum
sollte der iran wieder mit den usa
verhandeln wollen inwieweit ist es
möglich ist ein neues abkommen zu
erreichen und wie real ist die gefahr
dass der iran eine atombombe entwickelt
schauen uns das alles doch mal gleich
etwas genauer
[Musik]
was wollt ihr denn
nach diesem kurzen streifzug durch die
geschichte kennt wieder nach wien zurück
vergesst aber nicht wer unsere
protagonisten sind china russland
großbritannien die vereinigten staaten
die europäische union und der iran es
stimmt dass er sich um sehr
unterschiedliche länder handelt die oft
nicht gut miteinander auskommen doch in
diesem fall wohl sie alle das gleiche
ein atom abkommen und warum behaupten
wir das gut legen wir das ganze mal
stückchenweise unter die lupe
wer sicher wisst ist der iran nicht dass
alle glücklichste land der welt ja er
verfügt über fast so viele ölreserven
wie saudi arabien und auch über die
zweitgrößten erdgasreserven der welt nur
russland besitzt mehr somit ist eine
echte energie supermacht aber diese
ressourcen nutzen dem land wenig denn
ihr verkauf ist kaum möglich der grund
dafür ist der folgende
us-regierungsbeamter die usa wärme
sanktionen gegen jeden verhängen der
iranische öl kauft mit anderen worten
die usa kaufen nicht nur kein öl aus dem
iran sie machen es auch anderen ländern
sehr schwer indem sie die iranischen
ausfuhren durch sanktionen beschränkt
haben diese sanktionen wiederum stehen
in engem zusammenhang mit dem iranischen
atomprogramm dadurch liegt die iranische
wirtschaft am boden
[Musik]
und kennt ihr vielleicht noch etwas das
der iranischen wirtschaft schadet
richtig die korona krise und natürlich
tut das regime alles was es kann um
diese probleme in den griff zu bekommen
aber wie nun mit einer bewährten und
narren sicheren strategie
die reihe bietet zeitungen die den
obersten führer mit armut in verbindung
brachte ja wir sprechen von zensur es
tut mir leid wenn ihr etwas anderes
erwartet habt vielleicht werdet ihr
sagen okay eventuell ist dem regime
seine bevölkerung egal aber kann sich
das land angesichts des wirtschaftlichen
chaos und der handelsblockade wirklich
weiterentwickeln selbstverständlich
nicht
einen offiziellen iranischen durch
zufolge wird die inflation in den
nächsten fünf jahren auf krasse 65
prozent steigen wenn die sanktionen
bestehen bleiben das ist ein
katastrophales niveau dabei klingt die
lösung so einfach die sanktionen müssen
aufgehoben werden tatsächlich stieg das
iranische bruttoinlandsprodukt nach der
aufhebung der sanktionen im rahmen des
letzten atom abkommens um ganze 14
prozentpunkte an doch damit sich dies
wiederholt müssten aufhören mit atomen
zu spielen und mit verhandlungen
beginnen wie er es schon im jahr 2015
getan hat doch wieso wollen die übrigen
länder überhaupt wieder mit dem iran
verhandeln dafür gibt es mindestens drei
gründe erstens niemand will dass der
iran die atombombe hat zweitens liegt in
beiden interesse einen positiven
eindruck zu hinterlassen denn er hat in
letzter zeit nur eine
zirkusveranstaltung nach der anderen
gegeben und sich wie ein seniler chaos
clown aufgeführt es ist ihm wichtig
wenigstens mit etwas positivem in
erinnerung zu bleiben und der dritte
grund ist falls das alles erfolg haben
würde können auch viele andere länder
davon profitieren denn wegen der
sanktionen haben auswirkungen über die
grenzen des irans hinaus was ich damit
meine so was wie das hier
übersteigt da trump schärfere sanktionen
gegen den iran verhängt ja das gehört
doch eigentlich zum kleinen einmaleins
weise so alle politik hier geringer das
angebot an erdöl ist doch höher die
preise wenn ihr also glaubt diese
verhandlungen hätten nichts mit euch zu
tun dann denkt an den iran wenn ihr das
nächste mal an der zapf oder ladesäule
steht oder euch die gas und strom
rechnung ins haus flattert
[Musik]
übrigens abrechnungen die müssen wie
auch bezahlen und daher ist dies ein
fantastischer moment um euch daran zu
erinnern dass sie unsere arbeit durch
eine kleine spende am leben erhalten
könnt den paypal spenden link findet ihr
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
ich danke euch schon jetzt aber kommen
wir zurück zu unserer geschichte denn es
geht nicht nur um energie wir sprechen
auch über alle arten von unternehmen die
vielleicht mit dem iran geschäfte machen
wollen aber nicht bereit sind sich dafür
vom restlichen internationalen markt
zurückzuziehen denn aufgrund der
derzeitigen sanktionen haben sie die
qual der wahl ob sie lieber in den usa
oder im iran tätig sein wollen beides
geht halt nicht mit anderen worten alle
wollen im grunde ein atom abkommen denn
alle wollen es besser haben kohle
verdienen oder sparen iran die amis
deutschland die eu und deutschland ist
übrigens an dem ganzen eher an
atomverhandlungen seit 2003 beteiligt da
die ursprünglich von den damals drei
größten eu ländern deutschland
großbritannien und frankreich initiiert
wurden deutschland und frankreich sind
historisch gesehen im iran
wirtschaftlich stark engagiert gewesen
und haben auch große teile der dortigen
nukleartechnik geliefert deswegen sind
ihr engagement und eben auch ihre
verantwortung in dieser sache ist so
groß später schlossen sich der gruppe
nach china russland und die usa als
weitere mitglieder des
un-sicherheitsrates amt daher heißt die
gruppe heute eu 33 oder auch b5 plus
eins die fünf ständigen mitglieder des
un sicherheitsrates um das plus steht
eben für deutschland also wie gesagt sie
alle wollen irgendwie mehr geld
verdienen die frage ist nur wie wie
stehen die chancen dafür das bild
abkommen wirklich zustande kommt genau
das lernen wir uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
das kleingedruckte
wie wir gesehen haben sind hier alle
länder die sich gerade in wien treffen
zumindest prinzipiell an einem neuen
atom abkommen interessiert aber denkt
ihr dass dies eine garantie dafür
darstellen würde dass ein abkommen
wirklich zustande kommt nun lasst mich
dazu eine kleine geschichte erzählen es
waren einmal eine krabbe ein schwan und
ein fisch und die drei beschlossen einen
wagen zu ziehen doch was geschah da
schwan war ein flug tier also zog er in
richtung himmel der fischzucht den
karren in richtung meer und die krabbe
sucht den car and nur ständig zur seite
so blieb trotz all ihrer bemühungen der
wagen an seinem platz stehen mit anderen
worten war sie jetzt mit den iran atom
abkommen passieren könnte ist so alt wie
diese geschichte denn jedes land in die
richtung seine eigenen interessen härte
ist das einzige worauf wir wetten können
wie lange es dauern wird ist das ganze
vorhaben scheitert
hinzu kommt die tatsache dass die
verhandlungen nur sehr sehr langsam
vorankommen die usa und ihre verbündeten
wollen zum atom abkommen von 2015
zurückkehren ohne ein komma daran zu
ändern es ist das typische hey es tut
mir leid lasst uns alle so tun als ob
nichts passiert sei der zwischenzeit
kein uran angereichert worden wäre ja
eigentlich niemals präsident der usa war
und danach gehen wir einfach wieder zur
tagesordnung über aber für den iran ist
diese option denkbar entweder wird ein
neues abkommen ausgehandelt oder die
gespräche sind beendet die forderungen
des iran scheinen auf den ersten blick
auch gar nicht so abwegig im grunde
wollen sie die zusicherung dass die usa
nicht wieder aus dem abkommen aussteigen
werden aber natürlich ist es für die usa
sehr schwierig sich dauerhaft an so
etwas zu binden denn zum einen haben sie
ja eine demokratie in der sich
machtverhältnisse eben schnell ändern
können und zweitens ist der eher an eine
diktatur war ja schon gegen das erste
abkommen verstoßen hat da fällt es eben
schwer sich wieder gegenseitig zu
vertrauen erst recht in einer sauce 7
angelegenheit wie atomwaffen natürlich
gibt es auch viele technische details zu
klären doch wenn er glaubt dass der iran
und die usa die einzigen sind sie sich
unzufrieden zeigen dann irrt ihr euch
frankreich entwürfe für atom abkommen
keine vernünftige grundlage für einigung
und das ist nicht alles vielleicht habt
ihr gedacht dass die delegierten des
irans all diese bedingungen direkt mit
den usa aushandeln aber das ist nicht
der fall die beiden haben ein so
schlechtes verhältnis zueinander dass
ich schon froh sind wenn sie sich in die
augen sehen können die verhandlungen
finden also indirekt stadt und die
übrigen länder müssen vermitteln der
iran trifft sich mit frankreich dann
gibt frankreich die information an die
usa weiter aber in der zwischenzeit
trifft sich der iran bereits mit
russland und china und hat
möglicherweise eine meinung völlig
geändert nur selten ähnelte die hohe
politik so sehr einer runde stille post
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und den rest könnt ihr euch wohl denken
mehr intrigen als bei game of thrones
desinformationskampagne und vor allem
viele poker face denn in diesem mehr
parteien kampf ist es im interesse jeder
partei sich als stärker darzustellen als
sie tatsächlich ist für den iran besteht
die strategie darin die verhandlungen in
die länge zu ziehen auf diese weise
distanziert sich die derzeitige
regierung unter der führung von ebrahim
3 ist sie vom vorherigen präsidenten hu
hani hani war derjenige der das
vorherige abkommen ausgehandelt und ihr
wisst dass alles sehr gut anstehen aber
ziemlich schlecht endete als tramp sich
aus dem abkommen zurück zog deshalb
waren im iran viele rohan ii vor zu
vorschnellen und so leicht möglich
gewesen zu sein das seien zwei seiten
die sich für den iran nicht wiederholen
dürften hinzu kommt dass der jetzige
präsident reihe sie vor seinem
amtsantritt einer der hauptgegner des
atom abkommens von 2015 war was also
macht er jetzt in wien nun geld regiert
nun mal die welt denn am ende kann man
eine atombombe eben nicht aufessen wenn
der magen knurrt und wenn der iran für
die aufhebung der sanktionen aufhören
muss von bomben zu träumen man sollte er
diese option zumindest in betracht
ziehen aber lasst euch nicht vom
langsamen tempo der verhandlungen
täuschen es besteht kein zweifel daran
dass die iraner die verhandlungen sehr
ernst nehmen wollte er ein beweis dafür
nun sagt euch der name ali bagheri
irgendwas wahrscheinlich nicht aber
eines kann ich euch sagen wenn die
wiener verhandlungen für die er alle gut
verlaufen werdet ihr ihn häufiger zu
hören bekommen
magie ist der neue leiter der iranischen
verhandlungsdelegation er ist ein
erfahrener politiker stammt aus einer
bedeutenden familie und genießt das
vertrauen von präsident ali sie aber er
ist auch und das vergessen viele
analysten ein verwandter des obersten
führers des iran ajatollah selbst ja
genau diese allmächtige führungsperson
die so wichtig für das land ist dass sie
nicht demokratisch gewählt werden darf
nur für den fall dass er kurz vergessen
habt mit was für einem land wir es hier
zu tun haben zur veranschaulichung in
den letzten 40 jahren hatte der iran
acht präsidenten und 0 2 ein toller nun
die batterie ist der bruder des
schwiegersohns des obersten führers ali
khamenei und ok sind nicht blutsverwandt
doch allein aus dieser familiären
beziehung lässt sich ableiten dass alles
was in wien verhandelt wird
millimetergenau mit der höchsten instanz
in iran abgesprochen ist und wenn bei
der es schafft ein vorteilhaft das
abkommen zu schließen wird ein mixteam
licher sicherheit ein gutes dutzend
stufen auf der politischen
karriereleiter erklimmen können
allerdings könnt ihr euch vorstellen
dass ein neues atom abkommen nicht so
einfach zu erreichen ist wie es scheint
vergesst nicht dass die usa ihre
sanktionen weiter aufrechterhalten
während delegierten in österreich tragen
außerdem sollte der iran weiterhin
feuchtfröhlich uran an und zwar in einem
unbekannten ausmaßen es ist klar dass
dies eine ernste angelegenheit ist aber
ich möchte euch auch keine übertriebene
angst einjagen
[Musik]
es stimmt zwar dass der iran in
kürzester zeit eine große menge an
angereichertem uran angehäuft haben
könnte aber es würde immer noch ein bis
zwei jahre dauern bis er in der lage
wäre eine echte atombombe zu bauen denn
erstens der iran hat die bombe nicht bei
allen gebäude und getreu der iran will
in erster linie abschreckung irgendwann
denn jetzt braucht er erst einmal das
paket euros und dollars und seine
bevölkerung durchzufüttern also keine
panik aber an diesem punkt gibt es noch
etwas wichtiges zu sagen denn es gibt
einen weiteren akteur über den wir in
diesem video noch nicht gesprochen haben
wohl aber schon in früheren dieser
akteur ist ein gegner der wiener
verhandlungen die rede ist natürlich von
israel
dieses thema hat jedoch ein eigenes
video verdient und wir werden es euch
mit einem update zu den
atomverhandlungen bringen vergesst also
bitte nicht visuell politik zu
abonnieren denn wir bringen euch jede
woche frische informative videos und in
der zwischenzeit seid ihr an der reihe
um einige fragen zu beantworten
glaubt ihr dass eine einigung erzielt
werden kann die für alle gut ist was
wird passieren wenn die verhandlungen
ergebnislos verlaufen sagt er besorgt
über das iranische atomprogramm die
immer sind wir auf eure meinung in den
kommentaren sehr gespannt ich hoffe also
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat was
ja gibt uns mit einem like teilt ist mit
euren freunden und vergesst auch nicht
eine kleine spende über den link in der
beschreibung was gut und bis bald
[Musik]